mais 1936 mai 68 ou encore mars 2010 et
décembre 2019 la France connaît des
épisodes de grève depuis des décennies
et entretient à l'étranger la réputation
d'être un pays particulièrement gréviste
mais la France est-elle vraiment
championne des grèves et cela va-t-il
perdurer la réponse dans facture
dans notre pays la grève est un droit
constitutionnel inscrit dans le
préambule de la Constitution du 27
octobre 1946 depuis le droit de grève et
les revendications n'ont pas pris une
ride quel que soit l'époque les
revendications restent les mêmes les
questions salariales de l'emploi et du
temps de travail c'était le cas lors des
grèves entre décembre 2019 et janvier
2020 et encore plus récemment lors des
grèves des raffineries chez Total et
exonmobil mais qu'est-ce qui pousse
vraiment les Français à faire grève il y
a deux facteurs qui fluctuent sur le
taux de grivitudes comme on dit 1 c'est
effectivement les conditions économiques
lorsque il fait froid dehors que les
conditions économiques sont plus tendues
qu'on est en phase de récession de
stagnation les gens ont moins tendance à
faire grève même s'ils peuvent avoir de
bonnes logiques de bonnes raisons de le
faire en termes de revendication
notamment salariale mais ils le font
moins parce qu'ils ont peur ensuite la
deuxième chose qui contribue à augmenter
ou non le taux de grève ce sont les
dossiers qui sont mis en place les
projets gouvernementaux qui sont mis en
place et là il y a pas 40 sujets qui
sont capables de mobiliser et de bloquer
le pays et de faire en sorte que les
Français fassent grève et descendre dans
la rue il y en a un essentiellement
c'est les retraites en effet les plus
gros mouvements de Grèce sont survenus
lorsque le gouvernement a tenté ou a
changé le système des retraites comme
par exemple en 2003 en 2010 ou plus
récemment en 2019 mais des jours de
grève et des arrêts de travail il y en
a-t-il tant que ça pour le savoir il
faut s'appuyer sur les chiffres de la
DARES pour les grèves dans le secteur
public et de la DGAFP pour les chiffres
du secteur privé des chiffres apprendre
avec précaution aujourd'hui on voit se
développer même quand je dis aujourd'hui
c'est depuis maintenant je dirais une
bonne vingtaine d'années et des arrêts
de travail qui sont des débrayages c'est
à dire des arrêts qui peuvent durer un
quart d'heure une demi-heure une heure
mais qui par cette conséquence même on
peut de visibilité et ne sont pas
recensés le moment où en réalité la
statistique des grèves en France a été
la plus précise et elle-même
remarquablement précise c'était avant
1914 pour répondre à notre question il
faut se comparer aux autres pays une
étude réalisée par l'Institut économique
de la Fondation allemande montre le
nombre moyen de jours de grève pour 1000
salariés par an dans une sélection de
pays de l'OCDE mais la comparaison entre
pays est-elle fiable c'est très
compliqué de savoir précisément compte
tenu des modalités qui sont différentes
d'un état à un autre d'un pays à un
autre si la grévitude comme on dit est
supérieure dont tel ou tel état en
revanche ce qu'on sait c'est qu'on est
capable de juger de l'évolution dans
chaque pays des modalités et des jours
de grève dans le temps en fonction des
événements économiques ou des événements
sociaux qui perturbent qui secouent un
état donné en tout cas si l'on suit à
cette étude la France arrive première du
classement en Europe et si on prend la
fonction publique en effet la France se
situe à haut niveau de conflictualité en
revanche si on ne prend que le secteur
privé ça n'est plus le cas voilà donc je
pense qu'il faut il faut distinguer les
les catégories socio-professionnelles
autre question intéressante que coûte
les grèves à notre pays et bien c'est
complexe à déterminer ça dépend de ce
qu'on appelle l'accord de sortie de
grève et de ce que les grévistes ont
réussi à obtenir et en fonction du
montant de l'augmentation de salaire
vous allez avoir les conditions de la
sortie de grève et donc forcément du
montant qui va être mis sur la table en
ce moment d'augmentation de salaire par
les employeurs définira le coût de la
grève le coût de finale de la grève et
donc qui gagnera ou qui perdra le plus
en tout cas une grève elle n'est jamais
gratuite et elle n'est jamais non
coûteuse puisque au final il va bien
falloir négocier l'accord de sortie de
grève il faut bien que cette grève
aboutisse sur quelque chose en tout cas
ce coût de la graisse pourrait bien
augmenter dans les prochains mois de
deux manières à mon sens imparable on
aura pour 2021 et et 2022 surtout
probablement une remontée des
statistiques de grève ça ça me semble
inéluctable parce que
surtout depuis la fin de l'année 2021 et
le début de cette année on a eu vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup de conflits salariaux
la France ne devrait pas perdre son
titre
de Phyto avec la réforme des retraites
la crise énergétique ou encore
l'inflation beaucoup prévoient de
nouvelles grèves dans les mois dans les
années qui viennent
[Musique]